i'm in the army i'm 18. okay drill  sergeant drill sergeants and my sergeant  braxton said hey  whatever you do right before you're  about to have sex ask for the idea  so the guys are like what are you  talking about he says ask for the id you  got to do it so you're serious yeah so  we go to a party all right it's getting  to that point there's three rooms that  are open hey can i see your id you want  to see my id that's stupid  yeah i know believe me i also think it's  stupid can i see your id no i can't get  in there you're serious now you have to  realize at this point it's the most  frustrating moment for an 18 year old  boy think about being 18 years old right  at that moment but i got to see your id  shows the idea she's 16. okay my guy had  to run out they're like hey we got to  get out of here went back to the base  right it's getting to that point where  people have to do such things to get  protected